hey it's Evan Carmichael welcome to
other technology Tuesday today I'm going
to be looking at and breaking down a
facebook fan page for one of my youtube
viewers Peter elvidge and given some
suggestions on how to make it better so
Peter wrote in to me and said would you
be able to check out my page all my art
is there my videos links but I'm locking
on likes to the page my art is something
unique and it's booming but my facebook
page is my home for at all pointers
ideas people you know who would be
interested in the page and he sent the
link hope to hear back so I checked out
the page and this is it and here's Peter
and here's some of the artwork that he's
making now when I first saw this I
didn't understand what this was this is
actually in Minecraft so he's making
these these pictures in Minecraft who's
got Bart Simpson and snoopy and a whole
bunch of other ones that he's made and
he tells a little bit about his story
here it says pixel artist Peter elvet
describes his experience as a blind
pixel artist and he's got 28 likes and
not too much activity happening on here
so Peter I have three tips for you
number one is tell your story want to go
to your page I see your face on there it
says that you're a blind pixel artist
I'm curious I want to learn more how are
you blind and you're also creating
visual art it's very interesting to me I
want to know your story right you should
have a video talking about your story
you on camera just looking into the
camera on saying here's why I started
here's how I do it tell me why you got
started tell me what you hope to
accomplish if you can make it personal
you can make me feel something that I'm
much more likely to stay connected to
you to your page look forward to the
next thing that's coming out so you have
the makings of a really interesting
story tell it share pictures share video
let me know who you're all about why are
you doing this why it's important draw
me in and I'm more likely to stay there
number two is time-lapse videos so I
love what you're doing with the art and
it's great to see Bart Simpson and
snooping and the cats and Dragons I'm
true
so how did you make it you know some of
the best videos that I've seen online
are when you show the process and not
just the end result but I'm curious how
do you make that in Minecraft I know of
Minecraft but i'm not a player myself I
remember it played one game and it
didn't fully understand it and I dug
this huge hole in the ground and I kind
of got lost and stuck and I couldn't get
out like this too frustrating i'm done
with minecraft so maybe at some point
i'll get back on but more of a league of
legends person right now anyway I
digress coming back to your story here
show me how you make this how long does
it take does it take you days to do this
hours I have no idea show me the process
because that's the cool part not just
seeing the finished result but how you
actually go about making them so each of
these videos now that you do should be
time-lapse videos instead of just
showing the final product and number
three is connect with other youtubers if
you want your message to get out there
if you want your message to spread send
tribute videos to popular youtubers so
people who you looked up to people who
you follow people whose videos that you
love watching make art of them make a
time-lapse video of them in Minecraft
there's one guy named Nathan Shields who
makes pancake art I don't have you seen
this guy online where he takes this mix
of pancakes in a bottle he squeezes out
into into the pan and he makes beautiful
art and he made one of me and as a
result I share it right i created an
artist page and I put it there and i'll
link to his YouTube channel and I'm
happy to go and spread the message i'm
talking about him here in this video so
connect with youtubers do art of them if
it's Facebook you want more traction on
connect with popular Facebookers who you
love and do art of them and show them a
time-lapse video it's probably the first
time anybody's ever made a minecraft
timelapse art video of them they're
going to appreciate it they're probably
going to share that gets you more
attention gives you more credibility
gets you more momentum so these people
are already individuals that you look up
to you respect you're following give
them that little tribute video and I'm
like you feel great it'll make them feel
great and they're likely to share it
help spread your message and drive
people to the page that you want them
see I hope that helps Peter thank you
for the great question for those are you
watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel see more just
like it thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon oh and believe if you
want more believe energy running through
your veins sign up for the newsletter
below it's free you're gonna love it hi
I'm Jason J reyez fonseka of ra's online
com and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and XD only newsletter i prioritize and
look forward to period